між собою чик у прези продовжуються в
прези все добре наспівно лисиці обговорюють
чи кіл центри чи константи чи ще щось а
ми Тим часом друзів маємо колосаль
проблему та так подивитись що Чим за
трибуну наша прези все про Спікер почав
слухати дякую наріш Я вас завжди чую
дякую вам нати якщо ви не видите і не
чуєте я вас завжди чую Олей олес тут
така штучка навушник не завжди це цікаво
але я завжди чую надіюсь що це не ПС
того Як до мене зайшли нібито лагодити
інтернет ебушки повісити мікрофон що ви
тепер мене завжди чуєте я хочу сказати
вам одне найбільша проблема
держави Яка це не те що у нас проблеми в
США це не те що у нас проблеми в
Євросоюз це не корупція Це Так
хворий наш Сус агресор і це той бардак
бардак та відсутність системного мислення
яке на чолі держави